you
what's one tip you have for people who
are trying to improve their game
place lower chess this is a lot of fun
these faster time controls but if you're
really wanting to learn you play slower
games 15 minutes with a 10 second
increment to second incoming 10 if you
can ok this is an hourly bullet arena 26
players at the start of this 127-minute
tournament let's see what we get the guy
that won the last tournament
try a slippery snake
the old snake baloney
stop b5 yes
Oh
around here how about we put a bishop on
d7 and a rook here now aren't they in a
pickle kind of with this move because
I'd be five at the end and I'm not
mistaken they're in a pickle what's
their way out
pen
I don't have to take that bishop just
yet
I'll take now
[Music]
let's get a flight square
target this night once more clean here a
pretty big time edge
here get rid of some pieces
nice spin now
slight square
getting some material
Queen okay this should be pretty easy to
convert now I have a time edge and a
material edge they resigned back to
Chairman the ol slippery snake watch out
for him
Lord butter noodles around too
all right let's see how they can bat my
pawn trio
stop b5 I got the bishop pair
they have that covered
let's back up Bishop here well they
can't do that just yet actually I think
I'm okay
night move I could take here let's let's
flush it away
I'll take now
another enough they're in trouble now
because when the Night Moves I have this
and the night on h6 is in trouble I'm
winning some material how much I'm still
getting this night the Queen us to go
here it's awkward let's circle the night
over here this should be a backbreaker
I thought at least just go here I don't
want to repair the f5 square
here
and I could get here it's pretty much
game over go right here I don't want
Bishop f4 9f5
let's get that Bishop out of there
clean trade they might win this pawn but
my knight is just enormous okay
of time just then
gotta go faster let's just push this
pawn to Victory Lane huh they're going
to go here can I get my book there now
got to break down the structure a little
bit
is there we go
Bishop check
a good coordinator
instructure
downtime back to chairman land the
fru-u-- is in first
okay I was trying to play against their
bad bishop there
he got very active he got behind enemy
lines let's say 50 players in there and
rule at hem is in first floor way tie
for first all four is all with fire
Sicilian
all righty throw a jab at that guy
up in and let's build up some kind of a
central light structure because I'm
prepared to exchange him off at any
moment all right maybe I returned here
to make them work a little bit harder to
get rid of this guy
okay okay with the light square bishop
exchange maybe they help out my rook on
the G file one day know if I want a
Castle kingside
um
a bit annoying let's take here
quick May here I'll NAB upon
out if queen h5 I don't see any great
discoveries with their Bishop now let's
just kill him off and actually in the
end I could land a fork I have a queen
bee six check in case of Bishop here
trying to knife into my position I am
NOT going to capture either rookie
actually I will because I want to be
able to Castle queenside without my
knight being pinned otherwise I would
keep that that's a pretty slick move is
a slick move I want to get rid of that
Queen
clean trade let's go here and they're
lining up
that bishop move should be for Bishop d6
there down a time hmm it's an odd game
all right
got eight all right we both have the
same yeah we're both in there at eight
can Drew Latin so let's chase them away
right now
capsure's okay
just about
capture I was going to say it could be
difficult for them to capture a finish
development on it I want to trade off
that night he's a really strong piece
let's just get rid of them
and
alright are you gonna kill me
and throw
away huh
so it's like a Mar del Plata variation
but with nice absent
clean trade I would love yes this is
excellent for me now there is no attack
against my king and I can sneak over
here there's never any break and I also
observe this is where the action is and
I have a I've pressure on the Queen side
I would love at light-square bishop
exchange in the other activating their
bad bishop
he's so active I think I need to get rid
of him oh boy um okay
you know what I am able to know they
could do this okay at least I fix some
of their phones on light squares I don't
know what I'm really accomplishing oh
yeah I get some activity over here
coupons limit their king they're going
to stop this they're allowing me to
break down the side of the board they
shouldn't have allowed that now I'm
going to win some pond and
unable to make some break but now this
game is it even going to finish
for sneaky stuff got that pond he's a
target he's gone now
oh man
down to the wire big bishops ending
which one was good which one was bad
they should have played b6 I think when
I played a my apon they should have
taken steps to fix their pawns on the
opposite color their bishop there
and I guess I'll sneak in a caro-kann
I am prepared to give that light square
bishop up and yeah math exchanges solid
structure for me no advantage really
well no advantage for me that's for sure
looking for something simple and we have
just that flight square where we up so
he's fixed on a light square how would I
want to take if Queen takes Queen forget
that probably h6 is a flight square now
let's see if I could induce this okay
now let's do this flight Square and we
stop this
okay for another clean exchange how
about let's be a pest just once more
breakdown this a little bit that's a
check I get the Queen's off
you know this is going to hit really
fast six change wants and no how do I
want to do this hmm
let's take here and then play g5 so
these two work against the light square
bishop they're going to try to target
this pawn let's scoot out of the way now
it's a passed pawn so that should be a
pretty big problem I have a check to
pick up the H con they can't enter my
knight my knight covers that my knight
is a really strong piece
[Music]
for this
on the bishop again moving very slow
runners in
don't play Brooke here oh my goodness
that was a terrible terrible terrible
approach I should have been more focused
on time burning is lucky very very lucky
to get that one because they're able to
do fancy stuff like that just
pancha promote
you know how that goes any bullet player
knows
to make a dummy move an objectively bad
move just to shave a couple seconds off
your opponent's clock let's just stop
any g4 expansion I guess they're
preparing to a queen side with this
night combine what the rook should be a
monster and a half
maybe prep this a little bit I don't
want to see Bishop arriving on f5 forget
about that we're jumping in there's not
going to be a bishop here because my
knight gets here first this is more to
the point
clean c7 this guy is a killer
strong coordination here
start with this you know 95 I could
already smash through
you really have something here
let's see about that because I get to
take the queen with Chuck that's the
check and let's just be a little careful
here you got a check here and it was a
this is a shark right here on 8h time
edge let's just simplify
castle
look I know I'll get rid of him and he's
not going anywhere let's give a check
first I have him sealed off
none of you all right now take care now
that they're off of this and it's just
crash - now many approaches when you
have a
leading material
close to me and I have any time no time
back to chairman
okay twelve minutes remain
sixty-eight players in here now let's
see we get next alright let's try a four
caro-kann let's not change it up I
always going to take it into a Kings
Indian attack but a change of plans
oops looking for a five and clean here
going for an attack now let's launch
this age fun oh there's not here what am
i doing now there's not here okay
no lights guard bishop no attack or is
there now I can still muster up an
attack here get rid of there like a dark
square bishop
drop into this square let's go here get
out of this and okay I feel like even
without the Queen's on the board I have
an attack maybe council Queen side
put the knight try to play against this
bishop yeah I maybe did that it's too
late for that Momo just try to keep it a
little bit closed yeah that's going to
be a really strong Bishop did very well
to activate that guy and now I'm going
to drop that pond
maybe I can make him struggle so much
for that even on time
careful I got two dangerous nights very
dangerous you should be scared very
scared
structure let me add them got them
where's the forks Brooke here
careful easy
the bishops too good get rid of them I
could get to their pond faster just in
the nick of time one King and pond
ending
I tricked them
they don't have any time back to
chairman
man they had a instead of taking on d3
said taking my bishop they should have
Knight to f4 it would have really hurt
I would have had to capture with my see
pond and I would have a super backward
deep on and I don't know how he would
have lived okay
to familiar with this chasing away
okay you're going to play f4 and now
let's see
alright let's break it up now
okay where's that nightgown
five I want to light our and what about
d5 yikes
have five now
we've got to seal this up my life square
Bishop is a terrible
of them
some trades in here we deal with that
move
this okay
here
to cover these squares their night is
just too good
good move I'm in big trouble
oh boy I'm going to get made it clean
there's the ball game
never play into that structure not a
bullet game at least because there's
even alleys these ideas for f5 even as a
pawn sacrifice I got a fight back
so we're still even here I don't have
fire though Zhanna thorium and this is a
guy that I played in a game one I might
want to try berserk here try and fight
my way back
get a 3 with a W okay I might have to go
for fishing poles here someone was
asking how come you not go for fishing
poles maybe they're right around the
corner maybe let's try to address this
night he's in my house let's get rid of
him
alright he's gone and maybe we go here
okay dark squares they're going for me
Stella
back Bishop takes H - H - ok ok and now
taking my clean there we go even on the
clock it's going to be a time one all
right
easy to pre move now
two seconds one second anything
when I got a 320
twenty-seven
okay well if he keeps winning out and we
don't get paired up it's going to be a
problem this guy thought it was a glitch
that's going to be this guy's name
glitch glitch
he's just an underscore he's just an
underscore how creative
or opponent man he was a beast she
played on that underscore guy
[Laughter]
I should use plate age for lineup all
righty
my Center please
I'm lining up a pre move okay a cheap
little trick what's this guy up to he's
having a tough day he's freed up though
it should be five now three versus two
they say they they say could still do
this my bishop needs to give you
something else I got that covered now so
I get rid of the knight maybe this is
better
Fork they didn't have to do that they
could have pinned me I'm up a piece this
is really a rook I got three Brooks in
this position maybe he's worth more than
a rope Queen takes Knight they have
their chance
and oh there's a queen well it's been 10
3:27 he has 32 pack leader has 32 3
seconds they resigned back to turn
macoco go go go 32:29 if he gets another
one he's getting uh-oh this guy can
knock him off though how's the game
looking
they're going to get play on the G file
so I might be able to sneak right in
he's going to lose that game I'm pretty
sure he's going to have play on the G
file okay just focus on this game man
it's the only thing you can control this
game right here
oh this guy ah some of these players I
tell you I know you're going to do that
just love these pawn advances
Wow Queen kp3
alright
my bishop needs to play
soon just want to get rid of that night
there in a pin now what a weird
structure you need to go really weird
structure let's take
know how to win this yeah I don't know
how to win this my Rick needs to get
active there we go
pick up this pond to get the back behind
oh what's that a little boat that is
very helpful okay I could have just
given check straightaway I could track
that pond down playing very slow but
this is a win six seconds you could have
just taken off with that pond okay
hopefully zon sorry
get another game in
they're down on time back to tournament
that puts me just over the top
don't end notif rhyme if you have to man
known a frien I'm not going to get
paired up tournament pairings closed
they're closed I'm going to this game go
L cig no no no Frey no to fry oh dude
help me out man was it this guy no gonna
fry tactics ah you should have known a
fried man somebody tell send that guy a
message don't you know about Nonna fry
man
I'm down at this stream he didn't own a
fry I'm out of here so
Oh
Gamze to nearly all I'm joking I'm
joking
that was close man Sampdoria got a
buzzer beater in there he rebounded very
nice 80 and on long
up-up and that did knock me back to
second 34 33 28 26
let's see how the pages why not two
three there is
mr. underscore glitch and we are almost
there
as a fun one
in that one structure that was a nice
tactic though
yeah they deflected me I was overloaded
when they captured my bad bishop
but yeah they were getting good reason
for that for sure one apiece already
good games all